I've started on another book which I'm a
couple hundred pages in, I guess. And then--
Stewart: Was there a break between the two
books at all? Or do you just never put down the pen?
Neal: No... I tend to fall into a foul mood when
I'm not doing something, when I'm not writing
a book. And so I don't like to stop.
And also I'm sort of... you know,
putting the Long Now hat on for a second,
I am aware that I will not live
forever. And so, you know, hopefully
I'll live for a while. But I wanted to break
this habit of just stopping for a whole
year between books.
Stewart: Had you done that before?
Neal: Yeah pretty much.
So I just decided to keep going.
I'm also working part-time for a company
called Magic Leap which is making augmented
reality hardware of a novel type.
And so that's also taking up a bunch of my
time as well.
Stewart: Framing yourself into a
novel, which is the sort of the
original question... the idea for this one
sort of percolated for a couple of
decades... decade and a half.
Is that usually the case that you've got
a number of things out there percolating
and... one sort of comes to life or...
Neal: Pretty much, yeah, like the origin of Anathem
was when Danny [Hillis] asked me
and several other people to make
back of napkin sketches of what the
[10,000 Year] Clock might look like. And that
that would have been 01999 because he wanted it
for a millennial web page. But I didn't start
writing Anathem until 02005
maybe? And then Reamde is based on a
story of the Filipino hacker
who made a virus in the early 2000s that
went viral very very rapidly over the
whole world. And so that was
probably another five to eight year
gestation period. So yeah these things
tend to kind of sit there and ferment in
the background for quite a long time
before, you know... it's kind of like insects
that... you know spend a long time in the
larval state and they come out and fly
around for a little while.
Stewart: there's one story that artists tell
each other that may or may not relate
here. I'm reading a wonderful memoir by
Sally Mann, the photographer, called
"Hold Still."  And in it she mentions that
photographers she knows, and I guess other
artists, who sort of have a big ambitious
thing they're working on and they're
grinding away on it, they're grinding away on it...
And it's very exciting at the
beginning. It's all possibility and
some of them are starting to play out
and you realize you've got something
that's live and it's taking you
somewhere and you're completely excited.
But by the time you get to the end of
the project... it's all punctuation. Neal: Yeah
Stewart: ...grinding away and getting the last
misspelling out of it or the print
that's actually half a decent compared
to what's in the negative all I kind of thing.
And she said what she'd learned  from some
other artists (like, I guess, [Cy Twombly])
is that it's
the healthy thing for an artist to do is
as you get to that tiresome end game...
have something else starting to crank up that
is already getting you excited again.
Neal: Yeah. Stewart: ...so you don't have to spend
a whole lot of time on the: 'I can't believe
this is dragging on so long, can I just stop it,
I hate myself'... all that. You can go on to a
new mode of excitement. And then in your
spare time finish the punctuation on the
previous work. Is that what you're
finding this time around?  Neal: Well it's
always been the case. And it used to be
I would just get so distracted by
the punctuation, literally, that I wouldn't
even try to start something. But you know
the more i do this the more I realize that
I can get bits of productive time out.
If I kind of budget my time well.
Yeah, I'm just trying to waste as little
time as possible. Stewart: Here here!